[Music]
the left not just calling for criminal
justice reform they now want to defund
the police
it comes after two NYPD officers were
shot and another was stabbed last night
while protecting against looting this
new push gaining support across the
country including from former Hillary
Clinton campaign press secretary Brian
Fallon but is it warranted Tucker
Carlson challenging the narrative take a
look is our nation being ripped apart by
a total and complete lie a provable lie
last year the post logged a total of one
thousand and four killings of the eight
hundred and two shootings in which the
race of the police officer and the
suspect was noted 371 of those killed
were white 236 were black the vast
majority were armed overall there were a
total of precisely ten cases in the
United States last year according the
Washington Post in which unarmed African
Americans were fatally shot by the
police in two of those cases in fully
half the officer was criminally charged
is it possible that more of these
officers should have been charged of
course it's possible justice is not
always served that's for sure but either
way this is a very small number in a
country of 325 million people this is
not genocide it's not even close to
genocide it is laughable to suggest it
is in fact the number of police killings
is dropping no American should ever be
mistreated by those in authority much
less killed so Lawrence is there a
danger here in this narrative that all
the police should be defunded because as
we know when policing stops in crime
ridden communities the people who suffer
the most are those who have no defense
against the criminals so let me push
back a little bit because I think this
so often happens when we're having these
these debates and this is all centered
around the the one term systemic racism
so let's talk about this a little bit
because we aren't on the ground and I
mean
Republicans on the ground we've talked
about this a little bit on the show we
are always on defense when it comes to
the issues that the left talks about the
black community so for example the issue
is not just police shooting it's about
you know what happens on the ground in
the police department so with the
Ferguson report you saw that it was big
government in there and they were
literally policing for a profit when you
look at Minneapolis you see in the
police department where there it with
the stops in the use of force that when
it comes to black Americans it's a big
problem there so instead of people on
the right saying you know what this is
our plan like for example get rid of the
unions and put our policies in there
when people say systemic racism when it
comes to the education system instead of
being on the ground and say you know
what here school choice people should
not have to go to filling schools just
because they live in the zip code when
people say that it's not safe in our
community instead of going into the
community like my story does a
Republican and says you know what this
is how you defend yourself these are
your rights
there is a answer for every single thing
but because conservatives on a local
level I'm not talking about the
president's national policy all right
local level is how you get things done
we never have a response so we go back
and forth on who's the bigger races and
who's not yeah Greg your thoughts on on
the defund the police movement there's
obviously that's bigger than it being
about structural racism it's a radical
agenda meant to dismantle society
because once you remove the police there
are no protections at all even for
minority neighborhoods and it the police
exist to protect us from ourselves right
without them you have Mad Max Beyond
Thunderdome but you got it to think that
that damages a lot of these arguments is
statistics you know white officers
according to one study are less likely
to shoot non-white non-white people than
non-white officers shooting non-white
suspects I hope I got that right
white officers are less likely to shoot
non-white then non-white shoot non-white
so if the police is structurally racist
its intramural II Ray
so that's not a black problem it's our
problem right it is a small number but
the fact that like non-white officers
are more likely to shoot non-white
suspects than white suspect that that
kind of destroys a racial narrative
meanwhile a police officer is what
eighteen and a half times more likely to
be killed by a black male than an
unarmed black male is to be killed by a
cop and that is not saying that the
latter is just is like not a big deal
because it is but there's a lot of once
you get into this statistics if I could
pronounce that word what you find is
that the emotions are real but
untethered to some very some very
uncomfortable facts that we wish to
ignore you know yeah you know Dana I
went down to Washington DC downtown
yesterday just to take a look at what
was going on and see with my own eyes
what was happening there were lots of
protesters there laying in the streets
and there were lots of police there who
were black police officers so the
question is well does defund the police
also apply to them well apparently I
mean he didn't leave any room for nuance
it just says defund the police and
Republicans should be so lucky if the
progressives and the Democrats want to
pick this up as their mantle and make
hashtag to fund the police their
election motto going into 2020 but I do
think there is a room here for some
compromise and maybe even some
bipartisan agreement because I've been
learning a little bit more about
concerns from both sides of the aisle
about police unions so that might be
something that where you can find some
agreement and you could look like it you
know when you when you say you want to
do something specific and justice for
George Floyd for his death to have meant
something for change that that might be
it
the other thing I would point out to
everybody but maybe specifically to the
left is if you really care about
refugees who are desperate to come into
America what's the number one reason
they want to come to America it's not
just because they think they'll get a
job it's because they're fleeing the
violence in their own countries where
the police and the government cannot
protect them that's why they want to
come here because if you have
safety and opportunity then you can
achieve something
yeah Juan doesn't there have to be some
kind of balance between police
accountability police are armed agents
of the government they should be held
accountable for bad behavior but also
not going so far as to put communities
that need policing in jeopardy for
future crime yeah I think this is a bad
idea to fund the police I don't know
exactly you know to me it's poor
communities that need higher levels of
attention engagement from the police to
produce good policing to make people
feel safe in their homes and in terms of
their stores property and the rest so I
think that in fact you just need good
police now if they're talking about
doing away with like you know some of
the delivery of tanks and military
equipment after wars that I think they
could definitely do away with I just
wanted to speak for a second to the idea
of these statistics because it's clear
from the statistics that I see that half
of the people who died from police
shootings are white but remember blacks
are only 13% of the population and
according to these numbers
black people are killed at twice a rate
of white people by police and in fact
it's not only that it's they're twice as
likely to be unarmed so again to come
back to Lawrence this point I think
there's more engagement and it's not
always out of a positive nature it leads
people feeling like the police might be
an occupying force and we don't want
that you know I just want to tack on to
Juan's
statistic which is and people can go and
check this I believe you're looking at
population and you're not looking at
police encounters and there might be a
change in the statistics on that but but
uh but that's for later